tras aterrizar en belfast el rey carlos
tercero emprendió su primera visita a
irlanda del norte como monarca las
multitudes se reunieron en las calles
para dar la bienvenida al convoy real y
el rey se detuvo para saludar a sus
simpatizantes
un saludo de armas marcó la llegada de
carlos tercero al castillo de
hillsborough la residencia oficial de la
familia real en irlanda del norte
hablando a una nación profundamente
dividida sobre la familia real el rey
dijo que espera honrar el legado de su
madre allí
ahora con ese brillante ejemplo ante mí
y con la ayuda de dios asumo mis nuevos
deberes resuelto a buscar el bienestar
de todos los habitantes de irlanda del
norte
la visita de la reina a irlanda del
norte en 2011 y su apretón de manos un
año después con el ex comandante del
ejército republicano irlandés martin
mcguinness fueron vistos como grandes
pasos para cimentar el proceso de paz el
presidente de la cámara del principal
partido nacionalista sinn fein rindió
homenaje a estos gestos ella
personalmente mostró como los actos
individuales y liderazgo positivo pueden
ayudar a derribar barreras y fomentar la
reconciliación la reina isabel demostró
que un gesto pequeño puede ser
significativo una visita un apretón de
manos usar la calle o hablar unas pocas
palabras en irlandés puede marcar una
gran diferencia en el cambio de
actitudes y la construcción de
relaciones sin feinn boicoteó la
proclamación del nuevo rey pero acordó
reunirse con él y asistir a algunos
eventos el rey se reunió con líderes de
otras comunidades religiosas antes de
una ceremonia en honor a la reina en la
catedral anglicana de santa anna a la
que también asistieron la primera
ministra del reino unido- listos y el
presidente irlandés michael higgins la
visita se produce cuando los unionistas
leales a la columna sienten que su lugar
en el reino unido- está cada vez más
amenazado con los nacionalistas listos
para liderar el gobierno descentralizado
en belfast por primera vez